skip
perfect so um
earlier or last meeting
um I representative Dolan had asked for
to see which
um
recommendations from the West
um committee on commissions
um recommendations were adopted and
which ones weren't and so we went back
through
and um it's kind of broke down all of
the recommendations from the previous
ones and um were able to update as much
or see how which ones were adopted or
not
um there are some
unknown statuses at this time for some
of them but um we are currently working
to keep let me interrupt you for a
second just bring Karen up today we're
going through
the volumes of things that you had
recommended had decided upon the last
inner
iteration of this and so we had some
questions about well it says they're
going to do this did that happen
so that's what we asked
graduate back and look at it so go ahead
so um that's that's basically on the
um we were able to see which ones were
adopted and I was about 12 45 in 2020
and
um house multiple 12 6 9 and 12 in 2022
and we went through and just by
recommendation by recommendation and see
which ones were adopted in full
partially adopted
um there are some which are
um we're either not adopted or the
status of those is unknown at this time
but we're still in the process of
um either confirming those or
um
if it if at all possible Works um we're
in the process of that okay and um I
know it's also asked about
the mapping for all the committees as
well
um it's as a reminder
what we had thought was one of our
potential
open actions going forward was to look
at
uh
perhaps tasking the our standing
committees
with overseeing or following up on a lot
of these activities and seeing which
ones
like if if you're the chairman of
committee X Y and Z which commissions do
you have oversight over or could you
have oversight over depending on the
subject
so we what we looked is for our
assistance to help us do some mapping
with this that these all map into this
committee and these all map into this
committee and these over here don't seem
to map anywhere in the kind of uh they
open so that one of the tasks was to
create that mapping for us so we said
okay uh the legend admin for example we
could say you have
according to our mapping you have 30
commissions that you are connected to
and
one of the one of the thoughts is that
we need to rely on that committee chair
person
to
provide some
either supervision or direction or
whatever whatever we decide
they come from that committee chairs but
first we need to know which Community
chair has what
so and that's that's to be completed
probably within the next week or so um
I'm not sure on the timeline of that as
of yet
um as we're also working out the same
list as um as Deborah child as she's
been working and she's also using that
she's also updating that list as well so
we don't want to make an additional list
on top of that and kind of
um reinvent the wheel is kind of so I'm
not sure on the timeline on that as of
yet but
it's in process
okay anybody have any questions Brad did
you have anything else you wanted uh no
that's pretty much I won't go through
and read each thing because you have it
in front of you but
um it's kind of the current status of
all the recommendations of the previous
um
sorry should we go through it a little
bit though so we know what we're talking
about except for the meeting
I mean we got
we got like for instance the issue about
guidance I guess it's sort of what we're
going to be that's on the bottom of page
two that's sort of what we're going to
be working on I think
so
um
but no it was I believe this came up
um the previous meeting as well but the
the guidance for
um remembers as their
um yeah drafting these
um study committees
um
again as right now it does not appear
that has been adopted but um
a Metro where I want in that process
that is if I I'd have to double check on
that but um it would be kind of by the
way that was discussed at the last time
we had talked about that if if a study
commission was to be enacted that we
talked about maybe creating a template
or OLS say I'm representative
X and I want to create a study committee
and
or a commission and here's the subject
matter we would ask be asking OLS to
come back to them and say Here's a
template if you're going to have a study
commission here's what needs to be in
the framework of creating a study
commission so that's what we're talking
about I believe that is I believe that
was discussed but as of right now that's
not what has been adopted or anything
but that would be right
um I spoke with the uh the folks at OLS
about that and they said that's
something they could certainly do
but we have to be in our Direction and
do that they wouldn't do that just
because they think it's the right thing
to do they have to have to come from us
did you Karen do you ever get down that
path off of that as well
I don't um
not that far I mean part of the problem
is what happens in OLS is a little bit
of um
a policy that's set by a particular
speaker's office I mean the other
problem that we ran into if you look at
the dates of the reports that we did we
were really in the teeth of covid and
things got a little bit uh sidelined
along the way but
I mean with your forbearance could could
I just like talk for five minutes please
and I can just sort of go through things
because I've been thinking a lot about
this and it does include a whole lot of
intersecting pieces
so I think
it's hard to know where exactly to start
but the first thing is that and I and
Deborah has worked really hard on this
in HCS is to know what the commissions
are that we have that exist right so we
have an Excel spreadsheet
um and we know and we're more and more
we have the we have the list of
commissions we have the statutory
Authority that created them
um in the Excel spreadsheet that we were
working with actually the the house or
Senate committee that had jurisdiction
over the subject matter was listed in a
in a column so you may find Brad that
some of that information is right there
we have the administrative agency that a
particular commission is associated with
listed
and then you know there's when when we
were working on it there's all kinds of
information about how frequently they're
meeting and that sort of thing to try to
decide whether it's something that
should go forward so
that has to be a document from which a
lot of our actions occur I think and I
was thinking about it instead of
us always trying to figure out whether a
commission is really useful or Not by
tracking how many times they're meeting
I mean I think in some respects we
should also try to get the
administrative agency that they're
associated with to take some
responsibility for at least letting us
know if they think that this has sort of
run its course or some of the people
that are involved in it
um so if you have that as a so you have
that as a bait you have that as a basic
grounding document and what was put in
the statute the last time was to be sure
that that is updated on an annual basis
I mean I think HCS will be updating it
all the time but that that's provided to
all the committee chairs right from the
get-go so that when when committee
chairs open up their standing committee
operations they have something in front
of them that they know so when there are
requests that are coming in they have a
basis to to
um to work on and if you wanted to have
somebody refine it down to just the the
statutory commissions that relate to a
particular agency you could do that too
so then the other thing I was thinking
about a lot of our issues start with
um somebody coming up with an idea to
have a study committee or a commission
and going into OLS right
so
I think that we should put together some
sort of infrastructure to enable OLS to
ask a few questions of these people and
to sort of require that the people that
are coming in with the request have done
it and one of the main things is to make
sure that those people have done the
research that they need to do to find
out whether a commissioner committee has
already been established to study this
subject
and it was pretty clear to me that Dave
uh you know the staff themselves at the
time of the request doesn't have the
time to go back and do the research
themselves so if we have this basic
document it shouldn't be that hard to do
that research especially if it's
available on the on the website
so
the other thing that I think we need to
do and work with Els Is AO OLS in what
you were saying is to come up with a
template for study committees and
commissions things that will always be
in there and those things should be
shared not only with members but with
and you know there should be a mutual
understanding of what these things will
include including reporting requirements
repeal dates and all that sort of thing
and I think one of the tasks of this
committee could be what what we think
any well-structured commission or study
committee should have in it like
clear reporting requirements membership
clear direction of what they're going to
study all that sort of thing and I think
we could do everybody a good service if
we kind of worked out a template for
because that's where a lot of these
issues start is right at OS when people
march in the door right
the other issue that comes up is that
members come in with ideas of who they
want as members of these commissions if
their statutory commissions and they
don't even reach out to find out whether
like a certain entity even wants to
participate
and sometimes they have the wrong name
of the organization
and
then if a bill passes that these things
aren't corrected it falls on house
committee services to work all that
stuff out and that's I think part of
what really drives them crazy so you
know people always like to have bia on
their commissions and then the Bia is
like you know we have to prioritize our
lives too and we can't
we can't be on 10 commissions let me
interject also
I'm hearing from the current speaker and
the previous speaker that
unfortunately
our fellow members
will campaign for a study Commission
and then when when it gets to the cusp
of
putting it in place and appointments
they say that's great but don't put me
on it even when it was there I did put
the commission together so I wonder if
as a group we might put a rule if you
will in effect that say if you're an
advocate for a study commission you want
it done you've got to serve on it and
that might well and I think in as part
of our
charge we need to think about my my
thought is this that we're going to set
up some sort of infrastructure
that people can always work off of and
one of one part of the infrastructure
would be if a committee is assessing
whether to create a study committee or a
commission
have a conversation with the members of
the committee at the time and see who's
interested in actually working on it
right but there are other things that
that could always be part of the
analysis like you could provide this to
a committee chair or to commuse like is
this a subject that is really timely is
this something that a study committee
can really handle you know
is there somebody else that could be
studying it or is studying it presently
I mean I think there's a whole series of
questions if we write them down we could
provide them to committee chairs and
they could use that as a way of
informing whether a study committee
could go forward and I don't mean to
interrupt that no no it's fine I'm sorry
I just have all the stuff in my head and
I just want to get it out but I think we
need to hear right so
I mean actually somebody was asking me
today whether a study committee should
be formed and I that was what I was I
was thinking about all the things that
could be asked because part of I mean
the the other thing is that
study committees do provide an
unbelievably useful service and you
don't want to be like randomly snuffing
them out just because you want to keep
the numbers down I mean if it's a really
important topic that should be studied
and it can be studied in the context of
like a six-week period
it can be really really good there was
there was one I'm sure on another
committee that I serve on I serve on the
Edna committee and one of the things
that we ran into recently this past
spring was
a a bureau of Bureau of Statistics type
of commission said well we need to be
studying
how many of this kind of person is
participating about this kind of person
and this you know these types of
Statistics that we need and it came to
light that UNH is already doing uh at a
very detailed level so why can't we just
take advantage of of the statistics that
they're creating and not have to
duplicate it with another study
commission at the state house so we
decided to do that and we killed the the
uh well and that's the kind of thing now
that might not end up on our Excel our
Master list but that's the kind of
research right I mean conversely you
know there are long-standing statutory
commissions that have their own
um statutory responsibilities and just
because they're studying an overall
topic that relates to a particular study
committee the legislature is suggesting
you can't assume that just because the
legislature wants it studied that
statutory commission is going to jump on
the issue and just do it
and and we have that's all that's all
part of it but I really think as a
committee here we could do some really
good work on like telling chairs what
we're telling committees what they
should be assessing when they're
deciding if something should go forward
and making sure that the Committees have
the information on what already exists
and that's what has been what had been
missing like
years ago
thank you chairman um
representative evil one of the things
that we've been talking about is how can
we encourage uh standing committees to
do some of the research themselves
rather than creating a new committee do
you
would you imagine as you're providing
guidance as we're providing guidance to
all the committee chairs that one of the
things we're asking as well is is this
something that this committee could do
either through uh you know a
subcommittee or an ad hoc committee or
something like that
and I think there's a lot of people that
want to encourage
I don't I mean I think that's great if
they'll do it that's part of the that's
part of the Char I mean the other thing
we had an idea you know when the
committee of committees that it actually
would be ledge admin that would meet on
an ad hoc basis to review existing
committee and commissions
um but I TR you know we tried to put
that through rules and and it got killed
and then the other thing that um
in I think it was HB 1269 we tried to
stud we tried to um establish a
committee on committees not unlike this
but it would be done on and so it would
be a committee that would be reviewing
everything that exists like on a very
structured ongoing basis because the the
problem is if nobody is reviewing what's
been going on and what's created 10
years can pass and all of a sudden
there's so many things everybody's head
explodes and then they dig in again and
as part of the infrastructure maybe we
can create here we want to put together
a system where these things are
constantly updated and reviewed and
assessed
but not by bringing every agency in
every other year because it takes them
you know forever
to come in it's just way too much work
anyway sorry to go on and on but that's
sort of my idea that's that's a good
idea we value that because of the
experience you've had or we really
really appreciate that and you also have
some thoughts that they want to
put on the tables before we get
uh continue yeah
thank you Mr chairman I I want to pick
up on actually you know it was something
that you brought up which was uh you
know Edna you know recognizing that UNH
is already doing
um some of this work around uh
demographics and statistics and things
like that
um I I think the university system is an
incredible could be at a really
incredible partner uh in doing some of
this research supporting study
committees and commissions
um the commission that I chaired uh
during my freshman term we had students
from Dartmouth College their school of
public policy reach out to ask if they
could be helpful and supportive and they
um helped design a website helped it
helped pull together a bunch of research
for us and we I I found it incredibly
beneficial
um I will say I'm biased as a graduate
of the school of public policy at UNH
um but know that they're always looking
for projects to put students on that
aren't just busy work right that could
actually be relevant to
um you know the future of the state so
um you know if it would be helpful to
bring in folks from Carson school public
policy a UNH or political science
departments at Plymouth 13.
um you know I think as a as a funding
partner for the University system
um I don't think we should hesitate to
to reach out and figure out if there are
ways that we could partner in ways that
are mutually beneficial
I I just uh but I have by the way uh
there's a
now I'm going to embarrass myself
because I can't remember a last name is
is it who is the an adna the uh Abenaki
uh woman Shelley yeah
I talked to Shelley uh Sherry Sherry I
talked to Sherry and uh
she was nervous that our activity
was going to kill the
Commission on
on Native Americans
and she she plead with me if I could
please intervene I said don't worry
about that that's not what that's not
what we're about to do
but there are there are issues like that
that some people are are very
wedded to often use that term and that
find a lot of value
in those commissions as standing
commissions that probably should never
go away
because of the of the important work
that they do so
I think it's part of our activity we
ought to try to root those out and make
just
you know build a fencer on them if you
will to make sure that they that they
don't get swept up in some
some general
cancellation activity that that we might
not want to see yes ma'am
uh thank you Mr chairman I mean I I at
least it sounded like from last week if
we were talking about and today some
sort of template or flowchart or however
imagining it
I would hope that that wouldn't if these
understanding communities that are
meeting and that are hitting Milestones
or goals that they've set out or some
way that they're able to check those
boxes that hopefully we wouldn't
they wouldn't get caught up in that room
right if the whole idea you would hope
so but I know I wonder if I'm trying to
imagine what that scenario is where we
would somehow cancel well I know I know
Vanessa looked at one
um
if I characterize it incorrectly correct
me but the head and meant uh in over 10
years
so and you can't really blame that on
kovid uh so is that could that would
that be a default candidate I don't even
know what the commission is would that
be a default candidate to put on the
table and say listen you guys haven't
met in 11 years because it really makes
sense to keep this Commission in place
or should it be maybe reformulated or uh
given a new birth that seems like a
default unless there's a with an appeal
process or something if for some reason
there's some extenuating circumstances
yeah I would I like that idea is that we
if we find
those types of things and Karen you may
have found them too when you were doing
your initial research that
is a commission that may have been uh
you know the Genesis of it may have been
well thought out but the execution of it
just doesn't fit for some reason we
can't get
people appointed to it maybe maybe by
default
we push those under the table and say
these are going away unless somebody
the the commission themselves or
somebody's got to convince us
that it has value and it should continue
but just to keep it in
I would be my opinion just keep it
because it sound it has a neat name or
whatever but it doesn't meet and they're
not really accomplishing anything to me
that's a that just clogs the system of
of a potential appointees which we're
all we're all a source of that potential
point is something that's not going to
meet or they or they come to a medium
like this and they don't achieve a
quorum and they have to go back home
again
well I would hope that in the tracking
process that that Deborah Childs and the
staff have been working on will have a
spreadsheet and we'll start being able
to track it much more clearly actually I
met with um and
it's Gerald and and um I what what I'd
love to see is have
somehow be able to work it through I.T
that when these commissions and
committees are meeting it somehow could
feed into a template so somebody doesn't
have to be doing all kinds of work to
figure out who's met and who hasn't I
mean that was the
that was one of the huge amount of work
that HCS had to do when when I was
working on it they had to reach out to
they first had to figure out what all
these things were but they had to reach
out to everybody and figure out when
they'd met yet
the other thing though that you run into
is that there are a couple of committees
and I can't remember the name of them
but one I think one of them works on
County budgets and it has a
um charge but it hadn't met for a long
time so we were thinking we'd get rid of
it you know based on I mean we always
got input from the administrative agency
and I think it was HHS came in and said
yes we haven't met for a really long
time but you've got to understand this
this thing has a statutory
responsibility that's really important
and actually this year we're going to
have to go to it and present a bunch of
information so we didn't wipe it out
it's just really
these things just have so many different
iterations I have I tend to
try to have a simple view of the world
and it's always catches me making
mistakes along that line but I would
think if we had that mapping would have
been happen soon and we go we go to
committee chair X let me say here are 15
commissions
tell us which ones are are worthwhile
keeping and if they come back and say
these 12 got to keep these three over
here we I think we can get rid of
because they don't meet the criteria or
whatever we set up to me that that would
be invaluable
to for us to help make decisions
you know for legislation to to kill the
commissions or
recommendations at least to kill the
post so I mean the only thing I would
say is that we literally just did this
work two years ago yeah
I mean we just did it
so
I mean
folks can do what they want but we just
went through this whole thing so I don't
think there's going I mean I think doing
the staff doing what they're doing if
there are a few like two or three out
there lurking that they feel like that
that it's time then we can do it but
um my other
what we always felt was that Arch on the
community and committees we weren't a
substantive group and I we worked really
hard not to be making decisions on
substantive matters but on the you know
the representation of the administrative
agency and the chairs or members of the
commission to decide whether this had a
purpose to fulfill anymore
um
and if there was a substantive matter
then you know it needed to be taken up
by the standing committee I just didn't
think that we should be getting involved
in substantive matters some of the some
of the feedback I've gotten from
the speaker and also
from the minority leader is that we're
out of people we got so many people
mapped into so many assignments that it
doesn't make sense for us to try to set
up a new Commission on
on Z over here and populate it with a
whole bunch more Representatives
because it just there are people that
stretch too thin to be able to serve I
think we've we found some
legislators were serving over a dozen
different commissions at a time and they
just they don't have the time to meet
and so so that we're at a point of
diminishing returns and we want to get
some feedback or we want to get some
goodness out of that commission but if
people are too busy because they've got
so many assignments
and they can't attend the meetings then
what's the other thing we try to do is
reduce the number of Representatives on
any particular Mission we've got some
pushback from that button I mean
I don't I don't know what you see the
next task it's being since we just did
this two years ago I wouldn't think that
would be the first place that we would
dive in we've got September 11th is when
filing period comes up again and I feel
like if we're going to do some good work
here in the next couple of months we
should be setting up what we think would
be a good template for commissions and
committees and have the speaker look at
it and get some policies in place so
that when members go marching into OLS
with a bunch of ideas
OLS is empowered to say have you done
this have you done this you've got to do
this and it's going to stay and and we
have a template worked out in advance I
mean I think that would be great
representative wall had volunteered now
that she's not here I can attribute more
to her volunteer than maybe she wants
but she had volunteered to at least be
part of a process to determine the
process to determine that what those
templates ought to look like
that part of our effort
ought to be looking at commissions that
maybe we want to turn off but also part
of the process ought to be developing a
tight process around creating
commissions and how it
would be part of it is to start out with
David who was here and telling us what
things got for his template now
and then have some sort of meeting of
the line I mean you know that's all
you've got to do but look at how long
but it's also going to be something that
they can work fast from right
and I think right and I think what we
can do
right some of the some of the uh
uh
controls can be we can go to the
minority leader and the speaker and and
say make sure
that when a commission comes up that
you're that these guys are asking the
questions
have you followed the template have do
you have you done X Y and Z in order to
fulfill the the needs of what a
commission is going to gonna and so we
look to them
to kind of enforce whatever rules that
we would put in place
power
off because what happens is
you know a member will come in and
they'll say all right fine in the Statue
here it says 15 members but that's okay
because I want 20. I mean and in the end
if they win they win and it can be dealt
with they get the standing committee
level but
I mean to me one of the key things is
remember have you done the research to
know whether or not this has been done
before
you know and if we have our 10 we can
have our Excel spreadsheet up to date
then it'll be so much easier for
everybody to do that research so to me
that would be a really good first step
especially because we're leading into
another filing period and the other
thing is basically uh what shall I say a
dialogue or a q a for committees on all
the things that they should be looking
at and deciding whether to create a
statutory commission or a study plan and
you you Karen you think it would be
useful that once we get this mapping
done so that we know that
see
well I'm just saying if we had if we had
a mapping that said
uh committee
Reggie admin your committee you get the
committee chair and perhaps Vice chair
in here and say you're you're
and you you are empowered to oversee
these commissions that are in place
supporting leggy admin uh have a have a
discussion with them about
what we're looking for and what their
responsibilities are and and for them to
give us feedback as to how well the
commission is doing or not they know
they may not they may not know and that
may be like next year sometime but I
think we need to make sure that the
staff whatever this temp the Excel
spreadsheet is that they're doing that
the related standing committee is listed
in the column so Brad I don't know if
you want to just carry that message
yeah I mean I don't think it's that I
feel like we I think we did that because
when we were reviewing all the
Committees and commissions I was calling
chairs to get there to get their input
um but I mean I I think over the next
few months we should be giving OLS and
our members the tools that they need to
better Define the process and rein it in
and then
I just was going to say one of it it's
the statutory commissions that are
really a big lift
and I firmly believe that you can do I
know you had a really successful
commission but if it's a really targeted
issue you really can do some fantastic
work just with legislative study
committees
of course it all depends who chairs them
I mean and that's why you put the
infrastructure in place and then you
might have outliers but for the most
part things should work pretty easily
I think you're right I I
my most recent experience with the Edna
is that is that the committee chair
usually has about four subcommittees
always currently operating and when an
issue comes up that looks like it needs
to be studied well looked into she
immediately assigns it to that one of
those four study committees and then and
waits
a month or so for them to come back with
feedback to say okay this is what this
is what we want to do and
we either want to support legislation or
kill legislation depending what they can
and it never never goes to a commission
yeah yeah I mean
I think Mr Sherman I think what I'm
hearing is that a template for future
study committees and commissions would
be helpful not just for OLS but also for
for us for us I mean so there's like
member education there's OLS needs to
have it to be like are did you go
through the the template right did you
go through the checklist and answer all
these questions and then committee
chairs and committees also need to
understand what we're expecting moving
forward and I think that can be you know
I think if we can recommend recommend
something to the speaker and then I
think the speaker can send it out to
members and then that's the expectation
so you so in with that that thought in
mind do you were you envisioning that
either this committee or something like
this committee would be a standing
uh
committee that when a new Commission was
trying to give birth they would bring it
to this committee for approval or
no
no because
I just I think that if there's a study
committee on a particular subject it's a
substantive topic and I think that the
topic should be reviewed by the standing
committee and not a bunch of people that
are on more of a
procedural committee but a part of what
they're doing is making that every
single standing committee is just making
sure that that they're doing it in the
way that we've outlined right the
recommendations that we're making
um you know everything from needs a
Sunset date or it needs you know certain
number of members and I mean all all the
things that we're talking about that so
I think that's like that's one bucket of
work that we're talking about
um after hearing you talk about you know
you weren't trying to make decisions two
years ago or four years ago whatever it
was now on uh which
committees and commissions we keep in
which we would get rid of
you just did it so I think
I think that
there should also be there's a template
for future and then there's a template
for sort of getting committees and
commissions in compliance
right it's like report dates like it's
it's all the things that are in the
template for for new ones it's just
making sure that they're absolutely
and that's a compliance check almost but
that that to me is actually that could
actually be legislation for next year
which is just let's let's update all of
them to make sure that they've got
they have clear
structure or all that and so then when
they're not then it's then there's a way
to get rid of them
so that was the question excuse me yes
go ahead there isn't the question to me
uh point about whether this
this committee continues to exist or if
it falls at someone else's
Lane
um for existing committees or even going
forward new committees that then exist
who fail to comply with whatever the
template uh boundaries we set forth are
um and the default should be that the
end if there's an appeal process if
there's some sort of
um opportunity to say wait actually
there's a reason we should be continued
to continue we should be allowed to
continue who did they come to us do is
that alleged admin like
okay so right I don't know that how
often would happen I mean it seems like
we would probably need some sort of
standing buddy to take in those kind of
but I also think it needs to be a joint
committee it should be a house aesthetic
because if these are created right if
we're creating my statute then it's a
joint so yeah
because the Senate just sort of does its
own thing it could be something that's
rolled into another existing commit I
mean could be I don't know if facilities
it's the right place but like the
proposal that we had in the bill that I
I put forth that was removed was that we
had a joint review
a joint committee on communities now the
way I had a structures and we're going
to bring all the Committees in on sort
of a rotating basis like
you know like depending on the agency I
had it all set out I can say what the
draft
activity here but it was a joint
committee and a very clear
responsibility I mean because the just
habit of expanding as that sort of a
joint committee it would just be
convened whenever it was felt
but I still I I have this hope that if
we do our
spreadsheets properly and if we can get
information fed in from I.T on when
they're meeting and stuff like that or
if they're fulfilling their reporting
requirements the ones that just aren't
doing anything will start to rear their
heads and it would become you know
obvious the ones that I needed rather
than having 100 technicians
and then the other pieces that not
everything needs to be in a statute I
mean you know if we have a policy that's
agreed on by the Senate and the house
then that would be in place now what um
I think some would but I mean there
might be things that you know like have
you done your research and well Ann
Fitzgerald would point it out
you missed this part um
pointed out in some way of a frustrating
tone
that the Senate
which has this language of was it 1449
notwithstanding that was that yeah
yeah 1449 which is supposed to be a a
governing
uh
rule uh but they have this language in
the Senate they use at 1449
notwithstanding so in other words we can
do Reddit whatever we want and we're not
going to follow that rule well I mean I
think that's just a fact whether it says
notwithstanding or not I mean the
members can do something other than and
it does supersede the statute I mean I
think one of the big frustrations and I
raise this at the first meeting is that
if you have a study committee or
commission bill that's initiated by a
senator and is a Senate bill then that
commission should be staffed by the
Senate and not always the house right
and there was an expectation I think for
quite some time that the house committee
Services would be the ones that staffed
it and I think that's something that has
to come from the speaker's office I mean
I don't know if you can put that statute
or I mean maybe it could but
um I I think it's really important
because that's part of the problem is
house committee Services has so much to
do right yes yes I think if there is
a template that we decide on and that we
want to move forward to the speaker
um
and then it's disseminated to all
members I think I think we should engage
with the senate about it too and just be
like can we all come to agreement that
either this or let's amend this
informally you know I mean I mean we
should we should have leaders from the
Senate come join us and say how does
this sound like will you testify
certainly favor or against the strap
language so that we can tweak it to get
it to a spot where we're all comfortable
with how we're gonna expect committees
and commissions to be
designed and implemented yeah and to and
the the idea being is to maximize their
useful
Ness yeah they get the most out of them
that we possibly can for the legislative
effort
and and
as a kind of an asterisk and this is
something to follow up with Matt said a
couple of meetings ago
is that when we have a change in
leadership in the house but if we have
to make sure that whatever we do is
linked so that it doesn't start it
doesn't have to start all over again too
I mean you've got to have a sustained
process
document
welcome
welcome structure
and then basically all you've got to do
is is which is a huge task let's figure
out the good points
right which is what's tough
right and as I mentioned earlier so many
folks
are so
taxed right now that exactly I can't
take any more appointments that's why if
you have a committing chair in the
senate in the house and they say if you
want to see with the study committees is
something you'd be interested in serving
on and just see what they say right and
I was asked about it when I brought a
study commission forward you know and I
thought it was really important that was
it was multiple times actually I brought
an amendment to turn something into a
study committee and the question was
would you be willing to serve on this
you know and I think it's a good
question I mean I think it's a key
question I mean the other thing when I
was talking about like establishing an
infrastructure because you don't know
who the people are that are going to be
involved and the the other thing that
you just you there's no control for it
is that if you introduce a study
committee bill
and usually the way these things work
the study committees are set up that the
first named member is the sponsor of the
bill and they're the convener of the
Committees and nine times out of ten
they will end up being the chair but you
don't know that just because you thought
it was a good idea to have a study
committee and you're the first named
member and you're the chair that this
person will know anything about how to
run a study commitment
right and won't and what you know some
people are far more organized than
others and there's just all these
variables with the individual but that's
another thing I guess in my
monologue I didn't mention but the other
thing that I know HCS has worked on is
to very clearly show if you're the head
of a study committee or a commission
these are the steps that you need to
take
and you're not going to expect the
committee Services people to do all the
work for you and run down the
appointments and everything and I think
the committee chairs can help do some
screening
along the lines I've I have personally
seen and I won't get into too many
details but I've personally seen
ideas be put forward forward for a
commission or a committee
whereby
uh
a legislator has made a commitment to
a constituent
that says uh well
I don't know much about this I hear what
you're saying uh we'll we'll put we'll
study
and that's kind of a way to get it off
his or her plate
and study and say you've you've met the
at least the initial request of the
constituent
but there isn't really a real interest
in that committee everyone shouldn't go
forward if you give X number of
questions and sort and and inquiries so
I'm just saying that this this screening
process that we put in place or this
template should hopefully be able to
root some of that out uh because where
there is some slang that one way to
to kill a committee a commission is to
study it you know death by death death
by study or whatever
and and that just I think that just
clogs the right clogs the veins the
other thing that happens is you have a
contentious bill on a certain issue
right and the way people sort of figure
it out is to create a study committee to
study it I mean sometimes that's valid
and sometimes it's not and all you can
do is really rely on right here it's
it's a prevention way to keep it from
dying right in some cases but sometimes
it's a valid thing I mean this is the
this is the challenge to try to make
sure that they're well run
and we don't create too many but also
not to Snuff out ones that are really
useful and needed just because we don't
want to have so many study committees
um
so but
I think that from a staff standpoint it
would also be really good to have some
very clear instructions on if you're
going to be running these things how it
operates and who's to respond and who's
responsible for what and I know uh they
they have worked on this let me let me
throw this out there just just so I can
say I did it what do you think about
and someone brought up a thought uh
that we should have a
a finite number of commissions
and if we're going to add Commission
C
and we get a Kill
one to make room for it
and that makes room that
theoretically
creates more opportunities for
legislators to be on commissions because
there'll be less commissions or there
may be one that they were on is now
now killed what do you what do you think
about that idea I think it's going to
hit groups of people against each other
unnecessarily and I just I don't think
that you know a studied Commission on
Solid Waste going up against uh study
Commission on future of Education
funding you need to mix I I think it's a
bad idea I think you everybody think
that I just wanted to get that because
that's been suggested so I'll say at
least we talked about it and decided not
to do it
I mean I I wouldn't want to be the one
to say that a commission that was doing
really good work should be snapped and
you're right I mean how do you pick
between topics what what
um Matt just said
and I think if the concern is not having
enough legislators to sit on these
committees
that should resolve itself in the sense
that like if they can't get enough
people not enough people are willing or
able to volunteer to sit on them and
they're not able to you know to meet or
fulfill their requirements and it'll you
know it'll cease to exist whatever
Sunset State we put into place it does
seem like heading up a set number I get
the idea of trying to limit people's
commitments we have a five-year repeal
date now in and that ought to help
um and if you don't have enough people
on it or there's not enough interest
so what if the speaker
uh if if he's responsible or he or she
is responsible for making the
appointments and
can't find
enough people is it is it now the
responsibility
of the speaker's office to bring that
back to the to the
floor to say we did we couldn't get
enough Representatives so now there's an
action here to repeal this commission or
what do you think
I think maybe we could talk about a
process of how to find people because
I'm not sure
um we necessarily
like that might be something that the
chairs and the ranking members of the
Committees kind of talk about and
um
because I feel like my experiences there
are often people out there who are
looking for something new and
interesting to do but maybe wouldn't be
the first people you would think of to
do a particular thing so I think maybe
part of the problem is there's so much
work on the speaker's office to do this
work of appointing that maybe that work
should be spread a little bit beyond
just the folks who are working so hard
on it in the speaker's office because
they have so much else going on as well
yeah Karen well I can tell you as Deputy
speaker when I was the person that did
worked on the appointments
so just as a preliminary yes the the
timing of the appointments is really
hard because you just take over the
speakership or whatever and you're
dealing with you know Bill referrals and
standing committee appointments and
seating and parking and and then you
have like two or three hundred people
you've got to appoint all these
committing commissions
so what I I mean what I did as a matter
of course and again if we have our Excel
spreadsheet with our committees listed I
did reach out to committee chairs and I
asked for their input on minority and um
and majority you know potential
appointees and then you know the other
thing that you find by the way we can
think about this is all of these
commissions some of them say you have to
have a minority appointee some of them
don't say that you know some of them say
you have to have somebody from X Y and Z
committee some of them are I mean it's
it's a community geography oh my God
it's just a really confusing uh process
and then a lot of times the speaker
isn't just responsible for legislative
appointments they're responsible for I
don't know somebody from UNH so it it
gets really um confusing but I think if
we're working out a structure again A
lot of times sorry to say it just is the
truth when you have a change of the
guards speaker to speaker there's not
there's
not great communication between the two
because it's kind of a contentious and
sometimes the policies that are put in
place by one speaker don't carry over to
the other one so one of the things we
could do is maybe helps me smooth those
Waters to try to get it what was your
experience with uh interaction with the
executive I mean commit commissions that
populated by the governor that's a whole
other issue
but what I was going to say is
in many cases what we did well the other
thing I want to say is frequently nobody
will step forward and say that they want
to work on a commissioner you might have
a few and then if you have some you
might have 10 people really interested
in one Hot Topic and nobody else
and what I honestly what I ended up
doing what we ended up doing is that we
got the input of various parties on a
particular appointment we just send out
the appointment letter
I didn't go we we couldn't like call
every person 200 people and say will you
do this will you do this will you do
this we sent out the appointment letter
and if there was somebody that didn't
want to do it then we heard back from
them it's almost the only way you can do
it because if you're trying to find 250
people to fill these slots on top of
everything you're else you're doing in
the first two or three months it's
almost an impossible uh task we can talk
about the governor's office
two
I just made me think of something that
came up with me in our first meeting
where we
to me there does seem to be some benefit
of like setting expectations that every
legislator will be asked to sit on the
committee potentially and that that
would be the doesn't mean everybody can
do it and there will be exceptions I
understand that but if that's sort of
the level of set expectation and then
you get appointed to something I just
think that would help spread some of the
responsibility I suspected would also
build some better you know
um ties between legislative you know
that everybody's sharing and some of
that responsibility and understanding
what that work looks like
if you come in as a new legislator you
know that's just you're on a committee
and you're maybe you're on a standing
a substantive committee and then you may
be appointed to or likely will be
appointed to another study Community
commission I think has Value Plus the
county delegation yes
well you just get the letters on that
they just they don't ask you that's true
what is
what is on the governor's office so that
so this is if I had a
if I had a wish if I was having to
administer these things I would try to
minimize how many Governor appointments
there are on these commissions because
it just takes four ever
and the governor is like okay you have
to you know appoint somebody from you
know who who who has Abode on a
particular type of water body you know
it's just
it's a really difficult task and it
really
um affects the ability of committees I
mean enough these commissions to work in
fact the first
committee on committees that I chaired
it was actually a creation of hb2
from the governor
to create a committee to look at not
only study committees and commissions
well commissions but also commissions
that are established by executive order
so we had somebody from the labor
department and a representative of the
of the governor's office sitting on our
committee on committees and not only did
we look at all the
statutory commissions administered
through agencies but also all the ones
that were created by executive orders
because the question that which we
couldn't we couldn't snuff by the way
that had to be done by the governor's
office well so one of the follow-up
questions is were you also Brad is uh
how many
commissions do we have that have no zero
legislators on that are only populated
by executive function by the governor's
appointments that may be on this
template I'm not I'm not sure whether
they I mean this well should we should
well the question is should we mandate
that that should be legislative at least
some legislators on every commission I
mean that would be exactly the opposite
I think of what we're trying to do is to
minimize legislative effort I mean I
don't think we monitor uh commissions
that don't have legislators on them
that's a whole other world
and I need
we could just keep going and going but
um I think that's a that's an area that
we don't even get into and then there
are several boards and commissions they
have to stay in place they're not going
to go away you know depending on what
their responsibilities are right like
jail Carr I mean there are all kinds of
things like that that we didn't even
look at
but anyway as I say I think if we could
set out create a template that OLS and
everybody would just follow that is also
shared with the legislators if we could
have like a a script for committees when
they're analyzing whether to approve the
creation of something I think that would
be really helpful as we're going into
this fall
and then to work with HCS and and the
Senate too but if you are going to be in
charge of a study committee these are
the things that you have to do
I think those three things would really
help move the ball forward
go ahead man yeah so
um if I'm understanding this correctly
we're going to concentrate on
being proactive for future committees
and commissions by setting up that
template
but we're also going to talk about maybe
putting some structure into past
the Committees and commissions that have
already been established legislation for
that that they would have to go back and
like put a Sunset date on
we can we can talk about that okay I
don't know what those things would be
exactly but maybe repeal or something
and um and instead of like going through
and redoing the work that you've already
done over the past three years and
looking at that low-hanging fruit and
and repealing those we're gonna
um kind of lean on the Excel spreadsheet
that they're working on and those things
will just kind of work themselves out on
their own yeah you're saying we can see
if that works if it doesn't we might
have to regroup but I think I mean I
think that would be great I I mean I
just think it would be really good I
mean what what my committee on
committees did was sort of look at the
past and try to make recommendations you
know fewer recommendations for the
future I think what we should really be
doing in the first instance is be
looking to the Future to how to to
impose some structure on the future
development of these things and try to
figure out good ways of doing that
looking at all the players like OLS the
standing committees the speaker's office
and staff and I.T
thank you and I apologize for being late
it was unavoidable
um I'm gonna leave early to make up for
you well I may be picking up on the
wrong thread here so cut me off if I am
please
um I've been on a number of commissions
and study committees and this that and
the other
um I think it's imperative that we start
also at the base in our committees
having the leadership of committees the
ranking members the chairman Vice
chairman knowing members see we're not
meeting as much as we used to and it's
making it hard for people to know where
people's strengths and weaknesses are
and what their interests are but um it's
a I think it's imperative to have the
leadership of the Committees recommend
to the speaker's office who they want to
be on these commissions and committees
also and we were always reminded years
ago when any of these bills came before
us in our committees
um to make sure we had details
as to what the commissions were to
accomplish
and deadlines for things and um if we as
clear Claire I'm sorry I'm thinking
clear evil back when I'm sorry as Karen
suggested
um look at the past to see some of what
has worked and carry that forward and
then uh add on to what has been
suggested by representative evil
because I in the past
I thought things went pretty smoothly
all in all but it's been more Awkward
especially since covid because we don't
know each other we don't know as I said
what people's interests and strengths
are and so I think when I'll as we move
more into in-person meetings and such uh
we'll have a better sense on our own
committees as to how to recommend to the
speaker to help the speaker's office
thank you
um I was just going to say one of the
things if we're creating a template for
creating commissions or committees um
for instance I'll just give as an
example when we were doing our committee
on committees we found there were
several statutory commissions that had
stakeholder groups but they were they
had like four and five reps
you know and to do their to do the work
you didn't need four Representatives you
could have two now I know in the statute
now it says something about having a
majority of the membership on the
commissions be representatives and I
think that's
I think that's an idea to try to get
people really invested in a commission
before they'll create it but from a
functional standpoint it um it creates a
lot more work for legislators I think it
creates numbers that we can't support
well and the thing is you just know that
that particular section of it is
something that any legislator is going
to go in and probably override in the
construction of their new
Commission
yes ma'am
thank you Mr chairman thank you again
and you're right Karen
um
I also firmly believe that we should not
be drawing people in from the agencies
and departments except for Testimony
participation but not as members of
because one of the issues we've always
had is who has voting rights and who
doesn't on these commissions and it's a
conflict of interest if we're working on
something that affects Des for example
for them to be promoting their own thing
and voting for their own thing that's
not fair to them furthermore in terms of
time these people have jobs to do and
they should be coming in when it's
appropriate to offer input that the
commission or committee needs thank you
yeah I mean I I would agree with that
that's just like this whole statutory
commission versus study committee thing
you're putting a huge onus on these
various agencies if you have them
assigned to multiple commissions time
that they don't have so
I don't know it's a it's a complicated
subject and you also have
when they create them by Statute you
just have all these different in in
um iterations like who's the convening
body who's responsible for Staffing them
if it's an agency if it's a corporation
I mean it just it gets really
complicated and then the other issue and
I know Paul has dealt with this is how
much we carry on our website how much of
it is required to be in our calendar if
it's not in our calendar how do we track
it
it gets a little eye-crossing but all we
can do is the best we can do
Mr chairman and I I also building upon
what Karen has said
um it's imperative that if the
legislature sets up the commission it
should be staffed by legislative people
our own employees our own staff that's
appropriate and it should be listed in
our own calendar as our regular meetings
are I I don't like this concept of
possibly having commissions meet across
the river or at the Departments and
agencies I I think anything that's a
legislative establishment should be
taken care of here thank you
well if we try to if we I mean that's an
idea if we have a commission
um
it should we should require it to be
calendared in our thing and then if we
work with it then maybe if it's in our
calendar it can fit it into our Excel
spreadsheet so that we'll know when
these things are meeting so if we're
trying to assess something that hasn't
been needed the data I mean I'd like to
figure out a way where where these
things are automatically populated and
it doesn't require staff to call a
commission and ask them how much they've
met in the last five years or you know
month or something I think that would be
really valuable
do you think we should be able to see it
as documented in the calendar how many
times they've met for example well
to
yeah but to figure out a way to feed
that information in in some over
document that we have for the because
that's what so when we did it before
that's what Pam Harner I mean Pam had to
do she had to call every commission and
try to figure out how much they met what
their statutory basis was what their
membership was who the chair was I mean
yeah
yeah it's just really hard to figure out
I mean
no you wouldn't and it took her easily
six months I mean months months
which is the document that's in here and
now I know Deborah's done a ton more
work on it
so so
let me take that as to uh to The Next
Step was what do we need to do I know we
we we're leaving Brad
with some additional tacit to finish the
mapping and another task was um
I wrote it down I just kind of figured
in my notes Here
well we talked about uh creating the
template for future study commissions
and representative wall had talked uh
at length about that uh
a few weeks ago
so
um
well
man you keep working on the on the
mapping exercise
um
do we want to solicit a a subcommittee
of this committee to to go off and
start working on that template for
future study commissions of what what
that ought to be is Karen
uh my suggestion would be that rather
than Reinventing the wheel we ask uh Mr
alakunas to come in and tell us what
their starting document is now and then
we make sure that it covers what and I'm
sure he will it'll cover what is in
there statutorily and we just look at
that and see what else we wanna we would
want to add to it and then develop also
the script enabling OLS to always ask
the questions like have you done
research is is the eighth which is a
week from today is that if it's a good
day for you thanks
okay so so maybe Brad you can help us
round up alakunas to get him here in the
eighth with that task as to
as to
what his current where he is with the
starting documentary we had spoken to
him
the first day that we we met so he we
shouldn't be catching him cold uh and
that way that that can be maybe the
kickoff thought process if you will for
for creating a template that we want to
create
yeah great okay thanks yes man if it if
it's an oh sorry
um if it all possible
um to have it circulated to us before we
meet I understand that he'll probably
want to explain it to us and it may not
be entirely clear but I think it'll be
helpful for us to start thinking
what we don't see or want to see or
rather than just getting it fresh and
maybe we can be more productive with it
when we do get to speak with them yeah
I'll certainly also pass it on to uh
representative to check
I'm going to be in Spain next Monday the
8th I'll go into a family wedding so I
won't be here but yes we certainly can
uh you only get
mileage
I mean we can start a little late maybe
that day
um
okay so maybe we could ask alicunas to
bring that
uh rather uh circulate that document
ahead of time to the to the 10 of us and
also uh you guys and probably Deb
and uh maybe Ian would want a copy of it
too uh
and that will help get us going in but
when that when alicunus comes and and he
prepares us with that document
uh I think it might not be a bad idea if
if a subset of us
es that as a kickoff point just to do
the
uh just begin working on that on that
Commission on the uh template study
commission template
uh that we can educate our fellow
legislators and committee uh chair men
and women as to what the expectations
are for
for commissions going forward and so
we'll think of this in the in the future
uh mindset as opposed to going back and
trying to fix other things in the past
or or to
lay some additional work on the work
that Karen did we'll try to maybe focus
on the new stuff
you have another filing period coming up
and there's going to be a lot of these
things proposed we might as well try to
do what we can right um in advance so
um if David I mean I would say we'd want
to know about study committees and study
commissions if there are basic things
that they include in them and then it'd
be interesting to know
you know what questions a drafter asks a
member in trying to structure these
things you know and then we could work
from we could work if I take that that
much I mean I don't know what they do
from the speaker and from Matt
can speak himself but for this fall is
that we would at least partially come
forward with a group of legit of
legislation proposed legislation
that we could administer this in this
next session coming up in this second
half of the next time
yeah I will say I
I think that is not that is an option
right I mean I think I think policies is
another thing I think how it gets rolled
out how
uh you know cheers are briefed about
like what the expectations are moving
forward I think all of that I think
those are recommendations that we can
make and if it is
something in you know if it is
legislation then it's legislation but
it's not necessarily okay right
it was my hope when we started this up
that we would I'd be able to do some
sweeping
activity to say you know you haven't met
and
in uh in four years you're dead
into that we have to have to legislate
our way out of it
right that's what I'm saying we have to
legislate our way out of
yes representative thank you Mr chairman
Karen just brought up something else
that made me stop and think about
something else about the drafting
um we are always reminded that we should
be in recent history to bring in as much
information we can for filing
legislation for the drafters I think it
would be helpful also for members to
know what drafters can and can't do
because they have restrictions on
Guiding us and we need to know what
those are so that we can guide the
legislators in the process so that we
don't have so many people bringing in
very loose or almost
pardon me for saying it almost
meaningless legislation I drafting is
critical right so I I think that's good
I think that's a good idea I mean I
think if Dave is available we could have
a really good conversation with him
about the drafting process up front and
um you know some of it is sort of in the
weeds for us but I think we need to just
right dive into them talking to him
earlier
uh he's a little gun shy about
telling a legislator what they can and
can't do
anything right right because he he's not
apt to at least right now
with the current state of Direction he's
not apt to say you really shouldn't do
that you should do this instead he says
that's what you want to do that's that's
what we'll do so we need to find a way
to get that direction that's why I'm
thinking of a template that he could
hand back to the legislator say and this
is the template that
uh
that the speaker and the minority leader
came up with whether they endure so put
it that way so
you ought to try to get your legislation
fit Within These parameters
and that I think that would be helpful
because I think like I said I think he's
a little gun-shy about
being uh
Clearinghouse if you will for
legislation
right
hey John
hey Mr chairman also building on that
um what you can go through
in terms of drafting you know
um I think I agree with Karen that we
should have Mr aliconis come in
not doing that
it's okay oh you're welcome
um the
I don't believe drafters can say to us
oh gee we've had 48 bills already on
Lollipops being allowed in the
legislature or something like that
um they can't tell us how many times we
can go to research to find out how many
times a bill has been so I think you'll
be very helpful as Karen suggested to
have Mr alaconis come in and talk with
us about the processes he has the the
drafters and the lawyers and researchers
go through um just so everyone has a
clear definition of what
responsibilities we all have thank you
yeah
yes ma'am
thank you I I'd also like to add in that
conversation
um just to at least start thinking about
also what the approach to amendments
will be like because I think with all
these retained bills that we have
um being brought back to the legislature
I think that amendments for study
committees and commissions might be a
perceived easier way out of some of
these sticky situations where folks
aren't necessarily able to come into
agreement so
um just starting to get that on the
table in our conversation with Mr
alconus will be helpful too I think and
and then one other thing is I'd like
also for us to be able at that point to
commit to him that um those of us in the
minority office in the majority office
will take some responsibility to to
educate our caucuses on the template and
on the questions that they should be
asking before they go forward especially
into that sort of retained Bill season
a great idea why don't I suggest that
that
in conjunction with elephants
pitch to us that we think about those of
us who are going to work on this process
that we include that that's part of the
output
to what the expectations ought to be for
the for the two caucuses to uh to how
they should brief
their members to what the expectations
are that you okay with that yeah uh John
where we are right now I'm gonna have to
have to leave I have an appointment
um
we're uh
you you can
adjourn whatever you want but um we're
going to ask uh Mr alakunas to come in
and give us uh some a pre-briefing uh a
handout ahead of time before next week
but also be here next week to talk about
what the what the starting document
looks like for a template for
legislators uh and uh and also to look
at things like is this something that
maybe Legend admin should be monitoring
uh versus this committee uh
uh and what's the uh
what what will be uh we just we were
just mentioning for the for the two
caucuses what guidance should be given
to the the two caucuses as to what
committee chair should be telling their
members
uh about what the expectations are for
commissions
it's either to create the commissions or
to be to be to pop be populating
commissions
we ought to be getting ready to create a
script for our our chair people uh
uh and what our expectations are for
legislators that are going to serve on
these commissions
as an aside we
good suggestion Karen is we ought to
figure out if there's a way we can limit
the governor's appointments okay we
should treat the governor's appointments
and I'll say this if no one else will
that because he might contaminate the
process but
right
um
and uh it was just mentioned that uh we
may need to do some amen amendments to
commissions and what should the guidance
be for those amendments
yeah well uh at the with that I'm going
to step out and turn it over to you
that's right
leave yeah um you said we were going to
meet a little later next Monday
um because rep evil has a yeah you're
going to be a little bit late would it
be I know 10 30 is a weird time but I
could definitely be here by 10 30. 10
would be squeezing I won't be here at
all next week so 10 30. or well since
I'm gonna have to beat a chair yeah
okay 10 30 is fine next week also uh
what I've been doing as part of what
we're trying to do is the Tuesday
there's a chairs meeting
of chairs and vice chairs which is uh
bipartisan and I know you you've been
there
haven't been there you're not you're not
such a word
yeah there are and what I'm doing is
every meeting I step up and say please
please please if you're going to have
committees or commissions okay a they
must have a Sunset date
and whoever is the prime sponsor of that
bill for that commission must be
the first named member
and you're gonna you'll see people
starting to back off you know that
so but and you you know it for sure when
somebody says you you got to commit to
it they're gonna oh maybe I don't want
to do this so I've been pushing that at
every chairs meeting and every bill that
has come through uh Commerce from the
Senate and the senator is testifying I
asked them face to face are you willing
to be the first name member on this
commit on this committee or commission
they say yes and every bill that I've
asked them to amend to put a Sunset date
in they have
so if we spread the word when all our
Canadian commission say hey guys you
know we're trying to clean up the
paperwork and this is the easy way to do
it we do it proactively rather than
reactively and I've had no pushback
which is great it's been bipartisan
so thank you
or maybe do you think we should offer
him sort of jump in but before you leave
should we offer both dates to Mr okunas
and see when he can be here I mean I
don't want to assume he can be here on
next Monday it's not a ton of notice but
oh he is you already he is available
next time okay you guys are on it thanks
all right Distributing
you
I know you won't be here I don't know
how you feel about not being here for
for that
I'm not sure if we backed in Spain maybe
he can breathe
maybe if you meet on Monday the 8th we
and we feel would be beneficial that he
could come back I'm not trying to over
schedule his calendar but if you come
back when
I'll communicate with
I'll be back a week from Monday okay and
I know there's
and I know a lot of a lot of us reps are
on pretty good for almost first name
basis with
Mr iaconis so it's not a problem to
communicate
so I know I am
okay
well I would
um
all right so I know I don't
know okay I'm not sure where we stand
right now uh seeing as how the chair was
vacated the chair
uh
what other issues would you like to
address and I'm I'll just speak for
myself I mean I I think we had a good
discussion this morning about what next
steps should be and I think
um getting Mr Alchemist in here to talk
with him about you know the process for
drafting study committee bills
um and commissions I think that that's a
logical place
for us to get going
um but I don't I don't know that I feel
like we've got a whole lot more to
discuss is that template part of the
going to be part of the discussion I
think the hope is to to find out what
what is being asked of members to
include in drafting currently so that we
then have that as sort of a baseline
okay establish a baseline first yeah to
understand what's what what are the
standard operating procedures as
I don't know that he has a template per
se right now I think representative evil
referred to it roughly as the idea he
must have some sort of
Baseline that he's working from but
maybe it has to be turned into a
template of sorts yeah I I agree I think
they're they're template over there is
kind of fluid
and what I want to do is you know for us
on these is when you have a committee or
commission to set up set up a pretty
hard and fast template with the options
you know if you need an exception you
must justify your
exception and oh I had an interesting
conversation with with Mr educonus about
notwithstanding
and he said
it will probably take an act of the
Supreme Court
to get that
put into
hard
notwithstanding 1449 no he said it would
probably take the Supreme Court to
put their fish down on that
so we're gonna have to deal with not
with sanding
um okay is any anybody else any any
urgent
things that we want to talk about are we
planning to meet at 10 30 on Monday the
8th then for tonight 10 30 on the 8th
and then probably back to 10. see I told
Tom Monday's my worst day
I have morning appointments I have
afternoon appointments and I had two
appointments this morning already
foreign I said I'll be here by 11 30 and
I walked in at like 11 29 and 45 seconds
and I hope you guys will excuse me for
that but you know it's
and
I enjoy working with you guys I really
do
it's a it's a great team I think we got
here and we can do a lot of good stuff
if everybody would just leave us
so we can do what we think we our
mission is
and uh
okay and well next Monday 10 30 and then
two weeks back to ten
whether he's here or not
okay
foreign